in berlin ist gerade wieder grüne woche
ja der zeigen sich die deutsche
landwirtschaft und unsere
lebensmittelindustrie von ihrer
idyllischen seite gut mit der realität
hat das natürlich relativ wenig zu tun
das ist im grunde so als ob unser
landwirtschaftsminister christian
schmidt jetzt seinen eigenen
bauernkalender raus bringen würde wohl
nur er drauf ist wissen wohl gar nicht
ungefährlich gerade fest oder da schießt
mir direkt dass glyphosat ein freunde so
hier der schafe chrissi eröffnet die
grüne woche
tiere schon du nicht so und wenn sie
sich jetzt fragen was aus dem frechen
demonstranten geworden ist hier aber
selber schuld tatsächlich findet gerade
gleichzeitig eine art umdenken statt bei
verbrauchern die immer bewusst sind und
auch bei vielen bauern die keine lust
mehr haben immer billiger zu produzieren
für die lebensmittelindustrie klar
industrielle landwirtschaft und
massentierhaltung sind schon noch die
regel in deutschland wissen sie mit mit
allen schrecklichen was dazugehört so
was wie hier
nimmst du schwein quellstein gülle gülle
auf der wiese schön gift obendrauf tote
bienen wegfegen schweinchen ausreichend
essen ist fertig nicht schön aber
wenigstens war und wir reden jetzt ganz
ausdrücklich nicht von kleinen
bauernhöfen seit 1960 sind 80 prozent
von denen in deutschland verschwunden
es geht um agrarindustrie geht um
massentierhaltung massentierhaltung ist
eine ist ein diffamierende sword absolut
wieso ist das gleich massentierhaltung
nur wenn man massen von tieren hält für
mich ist das viel tierpflege meine damen
und herren
teil des problems müssen wir offen sagen
ist aber auch der so genannte deutsche
bauernverband vielleicht die mächtigste
lobby überhaupt ich glaube die schlagen
sogar die autolobby strengere
tierschutzgesetze strengere dinge regeln
die sache mit glyphosat das haben die
alles hingebogen landwirte sind nach
rechtsanwälten interessanterweise die am
besten vertretene berufsgruppe im
deutschen bundestag
die kennen die realität mehr wie ich von
klein auf das bäuerliche leben vor augen
hat der weiß es besser
was an 365 tagen im chor oder
schweinestall romantisch oder gar
idyllisch gewesen sein soll hat sich mir
jedenfalls nie erschlossen was keine
romantik hat er vielleicht die falschen
kühe kennengelernt
es ist doch bezeichnend damit die
afrikanische schweinepest nicht auf
deutsche stelle übergreift stellen wir
nicht etwa die massentierhaltung in
frage
nein da wird jetzt von einigen ernsthaft
gefordert 70 prozent unserer
wildschweine abzuknallen
weil er über 70 prozent wie soll das
überhaupt gehen das würde ja bedeuten
dass das wir mal gezielt die bundeswehr
ihn zu über population regionen mobil
schweine wirklichen der dichte da sind
das da der wald mal mit einer drückjagd
durchkämmt wird sauer die bundeswehr
gegen wildschweine ist so ein hustler
die idee hier
sieg aber ja natürlich total
unrealistisch die szene ein hubschrauber
der vliet von der bundeswehr
news
verdammt
[Applaus]